I didn't think I was going to review
this film and even running this now I'm
still conflicted on whether or not I
should you see I've been exceptionally
lucky lucky enough to build a career
sharing my love and passions for the
stories that have given me and so many
others across the globe so much joy and
I'm happy to say that seven years into
the gig I'm still very happy happy to
have built something I'm proud of
something I can work on with my friends
and something I can support by now
growing family with however this time
last year almost exactly one year ago to
this day in fact it was almost entirely
taken away
easily the most requested story from the
past 24 hours 150 videos in a single day
Splurge of copyright issue copyright
copyright copyright copyright related
copyright system
overnight my entire professional path
had been stripped from me and I didn't
know what to do but thanks to all of you
in a select few working at YouTube I got
to keep making videos like I said I'm
very lucky but why bring this up at all
well last year I said I would boycott
this film and encourage others who felt
similarly to do the same and despite the
wrongs having been righted and all my
videos having been returned it still
feels weird to talk about this film I
really don't like talking about what
happened to me last year I'm sincerely
not someone that succumbs to anxiety
really ever but this was a different
story there's a reason I haven't
mentioned it in almost a year but I also
don't like the idea of something like
this hanging over my head ruling my life
for me I want to be able to enjoy Dragon
Balls films and TV shows again and so
because I feel like I should and a lot
of people want me to I'm going to review
this film however because of what
happened I don't personally feel
comfortable monetizing this video and so
due to that 100 of proceeds this video
generates will be donated to the Red
Cross this Christmas with that said I do
have a lot to say about this film and I
have intentionally withheld all of my
thoughts concerning and so as not to
impact For Better or Worse the
expectations of others online so after
all that Preamble I'm toying up Mark and
here's my review for the visually
impressive narratively interesting
Dragon Ball super superhero
[Music]
foreign foreign
2022's Dragon Ball super superhero is
almost the perfect Dragon Ball film and
I don't throw around those words all too
lightly having enjoyed probably about 85
percent of the film without complaint
mostly I can confidently say from the
outset that if you have yet to see this
film or are on the fence you can call
this my go ahead and watch the film it's
worth its signal because I think it's
Rudy solid and has just been released on
Blu-ray for Christmas if you're so
inclined with that out of the way the
film in question takes a frankly
refreshing and wonderful New Direction
unlike anything we've yet seen from
Dragon Ball story even when counting the
greater series itself because Dragon
Ball super superhero is first and
foremost a story about Piccolo and pan
two characters that have either never
been given a fair chance to lead their
own story or have been given a chance
with horrendous characterization I stand
by everything I said about pan in my
Dragon Ball GT review by the way the
point is going into this film having
really no expectations a keen enthusiasm
for Piccolo and indeed Pat herself and
the knowledge that Piccolo is still a
curatorian favorite character from the
series only further stoked the Embers of
my excitement as a movie goer but did it
live up to these expectations the
beginnings to this film similarly to how
Broly opened deals with establishing the
context and backdrop for this film's
action and Dramatics but in totally
different ways in fact each film takes
the opposite approach to the other in
philosophy of communicating the
necessary Exposition and in the same way
Broly wouldn't have made sense without
the backstory for the Saiyans this movie
too wouldn't have made sense without
this introduction or should I say
reintroduction to the story's main
antagonistic Force the Red Ribbon Army
Dragon Ball super Broly isn't a perfect
film by any means I say as much in the
review I wrote for it however when the
introduction to that story came with all
of its history and Preamble it felt
enriching because we got to experience
the emotions and set pieces which set
the stage and reinforce the motivations
for the generational conflicts that took
place later on in the film in a similar
fashion this movie deals with revenge or
retribution to a certain extent albeit
through a very different lens with
magenta looking to reignite the strength
of the one-time powerful Red Ribbon Army
his father created however this film
seems to be in a much more complicated
circumstance than that which the Broly
film enjoyed where that movie showed us
all the setup in history this one
decided to ER on the side of show less
tell more and get through this part as
fast as humanly possible and you know
what I can kinda see why on his face
it's easy to say that show don't tell is
a rock-solid rubric to follow in Earnest
but given that I think hardcore fans
know this story like the back of their
hand already and most importantly casual
fans largely don't care about older
classic Dragon Ball they may have made
the right call with this one in skipping
over this material however for me I
personally would have much preferred to
see magenta witness these Monumental
moments rebuild and set these goals for
himself rather than being told about it
because I think that's where the magic
lies however I will also concede that it
depends on the situation and seeing the
destruction of the Saiyan's Homeworld on
Broly would probably be more interesting
than seeing an orphan kid keep tabs on
the likes of Goku Piccolo and go fun
over the years with that said when we do
eventually get our first proper scene I
immediately fell in love with the
direction of this film prior to release
CGI was the massive awkward looking
elephant in the room and I like many
others feared what this movie might have
looked like I've been very critical in
the past concerning live action or CGI
remakes of classic 2D films and having
grown up with traditionally hand-drawn
Dragon Ball that was where my
preferences resided and largely to this
day still do however having seen Dragon
Ball clumsily handled in the 3D medium
more times than I could have counted
when I saw that our first view of the
film in 3D was through the perspective
of one of the Red Ribbon Army's bugs you
know those Android bug things that keep
tabs for the likes of cells development
well I thought it was not only
narratively cute but visually reassuring
swooping camera angles Dynamic shots all
providing visuals that were not only
beautiful but ones that would have been
exceptionally difficult to pull off in a
2d environment convincingly meaning to
me at least that this film wasn't in 3D
for the sake of it the medium wasn't
being used as a crutch but instead a
launching pad with Carmine his assistant
demonstrating his quirky predilection
for PowerPoint presentations magenta
sharing in his father's humorously
depicted lack of height and a misfortune
with tea and finally Dr hedo an
eccentric offbeat but importantly
different person to his grandfather that
he magenta wants to co-opt into his
organization and as a quick aside I
particularly like this part of the
conversation where magenta is presenting
Heda with visuals from his phone and in
one of the shots you can clearly see
that this is a freeze frame from the
game Dragon Ball Z Kakarot nice one toei
which brings us 13 minutes into the film
itself and truthfully if you were
expecting the same emotional history and
character-rich opening as Broly at this
point you might have realized that this
film is a much slower lower stakes and
more slice of Lifestyle to fare and that
might not be everyone's idea of a good
Dragon Ball film and truthfully going
into the movie I wasn't entirely
convinced either I was worried that it
might feel like something closer to that
of a TV special and one in some ways it
does feel like that from time to time I
think for those that prefer this lighter
atmosphere it's one of the movie's
biggest drawing factors particularly
once we get our first scenes with
Piccolo and pan
okay so I get sponsorship stuff in post
all the time but this is actually sick
okay
I gotta load of display stuff so these
are something called displacement
displays are super high quality metal
posters you can put on your wall uh put
it on your wall in a way that I've
recently never seen been done before
it's actually really cool and convenient
too there are tons of designs available
but uh yeah I got a bunch of superhero
stuff because I'm like a giant nerd that
way so I got it I got it I got I got a
doctor strange I got a I gotta I I got
oh I got a Spider-Man and uh I gotta I
got I got a Spider-Man again
what am I doing to play it to your wall
all you've got to do is use the cleaners
they provide to make sure the surface is
smooth and free of any grit or Grime
wait 10 minutes place your protective
leaf on the wall you just cleaned and
then put the magnet on and it's done
it's honestly as simple as that if you
would want some displays for yourself
then click the link Down Below in the
description it comes with a lovely
little discount in fact there's a few
levels to these discounts too I believe
also if you buy a display then some of
the money goes towards planting trees in
Africa so if that's something you'd like
to contribute to and get some sick metal
artwork click the link down below it
really helps the channel
thank you
this pairing here I was honestly a
little unsure of during super as we
never really got to see much from them
but this Dynamic on display between
these two bubbled up Nostalgia from the
back of my mind that I wasn't prepared
for we've seen how Piccolo doted over
pan when she was a young baby however
this is different now she's roughly the
same age or size at least as Gohan was
when they first met meaning now we get
to see that resemblance plain as day
through pen pen has her mother's
tenacity when it comes to wanting to
engage in conflict and fighting and her
father Gohan's kindness when it comes to
engaging with Piccolo seeing how she
offers him water thinks of him and his
feelings and how they both make each
other feel something more than they
otherwise would alone is a beautiful
thing to see unfold and only something
Astoria is long and winding as Dragon
Ball can enjoy to this extent there's
plenty of wonderfully endearing
character acting communicated visually
through the CGI animation whether it be
pans always trying to do right by
Piccolo her losing her footing the way
Piccolo his phone are even the way he
scrapes Gohan's window to get his
attention these are all wonderfully
character-rich and quirky traits which
this film is filled with however once
the curtain closes on Piccolo's
conversation with Gohan and his smashing
new haircut the film has effectively set
up two stories It ultimately wants to
tell we have the villains in The Red
Ribbon Army manipulating Dr hedo and the
Gammas for the worse and Piccolo trying
to convince Gohan to take his training
seriously for the better something he
ultimately ends up manipulating him to
do it's a wonderful set of contrasting
circumstances with plenty of history and
potential specific to both Gohan Piccolo
and indeed the Red Ribbon Army itself at
this point I was thrilled to see where
this story would go
ladies and gentlemen let me introduce
you to possibly my new favorite
character in modern Dragon Ball or at
least one of them one of the two
superhero themed Androids created by Dr
hedo gamma 2 is easily the most
boisterous of the two with a strong
presence and flashy skill set in a
refreshing way mind you poses giant text
appearing as if it were a comic strip if
it wasn't for the terrific action
accompanying this you'd forget this
wasn't straight from the pages of a
manga and I will absolutely take this as
my first of many opportunities to
analyze the music of this film because I
loved it despite the sudden shift away
from what we were familiar with during
Dragon Ball Super's anime and the Broly
film respectively newcomer composer
naoki Sato brings something entirely
more restrained to the table of Dragon
Ball super superhero that Sumitomo
didn't with his master class on Broly
and in being the temporary successor to
Modern Dragon Ball's Mainstay composer
Mr norohito Sumitomo it's only natural
to notice the differences in their
approaches of these two films while
Sumitomo was known for boisterous fight
tracks a wide variety of motifs and a
varied range of instrumentation Sato
very clearly chooses the more measured
route for this film the number of
distinct motifs is small the range of
instrumentation is narrow and track
count is light 23 to superhero compared
to Broly's 33 but this is not
necessarily a bad thing at all what this
approach does allow SATA to do is very
precisely solidify character themes
associations and an overall distinct
soundscape for the movie Piccolo's fight
with gamma 2 is a very powerful example
of all of these elements the main theme
during the fight entitled the gamma
Androids is actually an extrapolation of
the opening sequence theme introduced in
the title track Avon title with that
same arpeggiating Motif appearing in
other Red Ribbon army-related tracks
throughout the film
foreign
[Music]
so already at the beginning of this
fight we were able to subconsciously put
together that very association with the
Army using that very relation however
this isn't to say that gamma 2 doesn't
shine through musically in this track
though his personality is far too loud
for it not to with that incredibly
high-spirited dare I say heroic and
uplifting Melody playing over the fight
signaling not only the fun of the scene
but also hinting to the more genuinely
heroic nature of the Gammas themselves
all of this is wonderfully orchestrated
with sato's Remy Spiderman as sets of
Woodwinds horns and strings it's
infectious and I utterly loved it
however while I do love this first
interaction between gamma 2 and Piccolo
both musically and Visually I do find
the series of events that unfold
following this encounter to be almost
too coincidental and remarkable to be
believable almost if it was simply just
the case of gamma 2 being negligent then
Piccolo just so happening to be able to
break into the main office without issue
then I'd still be able to you know
suspend my disbelief I have no issue but
the fact that this all happens and
Piccolo just so happens to arrive in
time for the bad guys to basically give
a rundown of their whole evil plan right
in front of him felt so on the nose and
convenient I just had to point it out I
still like a lot of the stuff that
happens following this but couple this
with a very fast forwarded introduction
it's just another example of somewhat
contrived storytelling for the sake of
story progression which can be fine but
it needs to be worth it so is it well we
get the chekhov's gun known as Cell Max
introduced in this film and to tell you
the truth when I heard about this
impending character I started to fear
for how this film might shape up if they
were to rely on yet another returning
villain from the past Lord knows I
didn't love Resurrection F I want
something new from these films were they
going to go the direction of
Resurrection F where they just bring
back old characters or were they going
to go the way of Broly and reinvent the
past well curiously the answer was
neither but I'll leave that for a later
section
this is perhaps the most mixed I feel
concerning this film with perhaps the
exception of one later scene on a visual
front the models for these characters
feel a lot more scuffed than any other
used in this film all the while adhering
to the same Breakneck and fantastically
impressive storyboard with these
adrenaline filled action sequences
however at the same time as this you
have questionable dialogue exchanges
where Goku claims to be taken aback by
Vegeta's sudden use of image training or
meditation something he should be
intimately familiar with however with
all of that aside the broader purpose
ironically enough of this scene is to
excuse all of these characters on
beerus's world away from the action that
takes place on Earth and ultimately the
scene itself results in Piccolo being
unable to gather the earth's greatest
fighters to combat this new significant
threat made visible through the likes of
Cell Max this isn't of course to say
that this scene doesn't offer something
substantial either something this scene
and indeed this film does exceptionally
well as I've mentioned is character
acting remember when I said that Goku
not knowing how how to image train was
strange well at least they made it a
plot point to call back to within this
very sequence Goku's issue is that he's
thinking to conventionally too
straightforward he's all about the
action and too eager to get into the
next big fight far too busy being
distracted by that to explore other
avenues of progression like Vegeta has
done in this film through meditation
whis even complements Vegeta for this
correct choice he's made but the visual
callback that I love comes in how the
film visually communicates this aspect
of Goku's character to us to commence
his sparring Goku is seen standing
almost falling over and even trips over
his own feet as he charges Vegeta who's
standing in a more advantageous position
feet planted arms folded waiting for the
counter-attack it's a subtle piece of
characterization but it's wonderful to
see it employed so effectively in the
scene despite the strange dialogue
exchange it stemmed from however as they
Spire beerus flirts with Chile and Broly
watches on the communicator rings off
the hook so now struggling to get in
touch with the most reliable fighters of
this era realizing that he does not
match up to the Gammas physically
Piccolo has a terrific idea to boost his
own chances
this is what is so unbelievably
refreshing about this film I love Goku
and Vegeta as much as the next guy but
watching his Piccolo is forced to use
his mind to overcome the challenges at
hand is wonderful to say the least with
the pressing circumstances forcing him
to examine what's at his disposal
including the same power-up Krillin and
Gohan receive Dynamic would serve his
cause exceptionally well I've seen some
folks online complain about this sudden
power-up through a wish from the dragon
but to me it's about the same as the
power of the other two received on Namek
and if those are fine for us to get past
so should this plus given that Piccolo
is a special namekian they were his
Dragon Balls to begin with and he's a
defender of the earth it's a power up
that's his by right more so than the
likes of Gohan and Krillin on manic I
thought and as Piccolo is reinvigorated
with his new goal of Wishing on the
Dragon Balls for this power the team
behind this film reminds me yet again of
their amazing musical work as Piccolo
leaps from the lookout with the cloud
swirling Khan and yajirobi Hawking in
his helmet is a gorgeous cocktail of
visual and Musical components that
complement and Elevate this occasion far
higher than it ever would alone
[Music]
track that plays as Piccolo descends
from the heavens entitled Shenron once
again makes great use of the very
superhero music trademark sounding
instrumentation and approach ever since
the first Superman theme penned by the
illustrious John Williams superhero
films have echoed those signature horns
across their soundtracks and this film
is no different leading in with
descending strings explodes into this
wonderfully triumphant swirling
cacophony of horns and Brass
instrumentation and once again does
fantastic work at getting across to the
audience the exact type of film we are
witnessing here this is a heroic Tale in
which even someone as often neglected as
Piccolo will meet challenges and be
forced to find a way to persevere and
overcome them furthermore you can feel
toriyama's influence oozing out of
scripts during scenes like the wish with
Shenron and Bulma every exchange has
some sort of gag attached to complement
the dialogue or undercut the seriousness
of the occasion in a tasteful way it's a
harmless addition but the notion that
Bulma makes such frivolous wishes every
year through the Dragon Balls is
hilarious
this could come as a surprise to some of
you but this scene might actually be one
of my favorites in the film the sequence
and idea behind taking pan back to The
Hideout with the added dramatic irony of
us knowing much more than the bad guys
in this instance is very fun but there's
a lot more to this scene than might meet
the eye on first viewing on the surface
the purpose of this scene is for Piccolo
to co-op pan into this scheme to coax
her dad Gohan out of being a bookworm
long enough to instill within him once
again that training is important however
there are some really nice subtle
touches this film adds to emphasize this
aspect firstly upon beating up this bad
guy pen immediately identifies Piccolo
despite the disguise he has on due to
her sensing his key it's a nice call
back to the first scene they share in
this film and further bonds Piccolo and
pan together in a natural way at the
same time once Piccolo goes again in
Disguise to reveal that pan has been
kidnapped to Gohan he doesn't notice
Piccolo's key and perhaps most
importantly doesn't even recognize the
unique and obvious way Piccolo scrapes
the window to get his attention he's
live living in his own world totally
oblivious and by that same token in the
same way this scene serves to further
Bond Piccolo to pan Gohan not
recognizing this to be Piccolo for me
further emphasized the distance that's
forming between them oh also this might
not have anything to do with the plot
but it's a really cute Easter egg I
found after watching this film for like
the third time as you know Piccolo has
made it something of his mission in this
film to infiltrate the base of the Red
Ribbon Army time and time again and if
you notice on uniform he's using as a
disguise and now wears for the majority
of the film it has the number 94
emblazoned across the chest and if you
go to chapter 94 of Dragon Ball you'll
find that it's the very first chapter
Goku infiltrates the Red Ribbon Army's
base and causes all sorts of damage it's
a cute Easter egg that captures the very
first 2D animated scene of this film
perfectly
this is also where we get our second
main musical motif of the film entitled
Awakening when Gohan ascends into his
Super Saiyan form as well as when Gohan
assumes his ultimate form once again
boasting arpeggiating strings and a
powerful brass Melody this theme is not
only fantastically heroic sounding but
it also mirrors the gamma's theme in
every conceivable way this narrow range
of approach for the two main themes not
only solidifies the Sonic signature of
the film itself but also does some light
storytelling of its own signifying to
the viewers and listeners that the
Gammas and our heroes are not so
different after all it's around this
point also in the film that the action
really starts to ramp up more
consistently and we enter effectively
the final scene of the film long as it
is one thing perhaps worth noting on is
that Broly despite being criticized for
having too much fighting doesn't
actually have much more fighting than
this film does with the important
difference being that this movie Paces
the action in my opinion far more
effectively where Broly's movie had
uninterrupted action for almost 40
minutes intersplaced in this film are
are plenty of character Rich exchanges
and plot progression moments to help the
action we do ultimately get feel less
one note as a result that said I'm sure
Broly's style of approach is plenty of
fans too it's all down to how you prefer
things personally continuing on through
the film however Within These Prelude
fights the climax both Gohan and Piccolo
get to stretch their respective legs
against both of the Gammas and during
these fights I love how they communicate
how different these two Androids are
honestly we haven't gotten to see much
from number one in this film outside of
scolding number two for being I don't
know two lacks but the style with which
he fights tells us a lot about him his
movements feel more deliberate robotic
even as if they're being delivered with
a clinical Precision the likes of which
gamma 2 never administered and honestly
it fits his much more stoic and
straightforward demeanor and in truth
these scenes despite them showcasing the
Gammas as something of unwitting
antagonists it makes me love them all
the more they're easily my favorite new
addition to the series
foreign
Piccolo
it might actually be a hot take I'm not
entirely sure and I know that this
character and this design gets ragged
down a lot but I think I actually love
Piccolo's new form aesthetically I'm so
tired of these traditionally handsome
Transformations for lack of a better
term and I like that this one took a
very different direction to that of a
Super Saiyan variety transformation
there's this somewhat predominant drive
not just in Dragon Ball largely but in
broader anime and manga in general to
have the latter forms or Transformations
act sort of like the swanning or
butterfly moment of the character and in
many ways I can understand why that fits
metaphorically speaking with that form
being the full realization of the
character in question however in a story
like Dragon Ball which has become
whether you'd like to admit it or not
inundated with transformations of
various kinds you have to consider that
if everyone is made to look special and
the same then nothing is special Ken
tsugamori the artist behind some of your
favorite Pokemon has come out and saying
that a big part of his success in design
isn't so much trying to create cool
looking Pokemon all the time it's
drawing a character that has unsightly
or somewhat dorky features that can be
mixed in with traditionally cool
features to amplify them I think orange
Piccolo does just that there's something
unconventional and awkward about the
design he's a giant Oompa Loompa but
damn it if I don't think that this also
looks kind of awesome too like that
dorky aspect of his design almost
highlights the badass elements and this
is all coupled with the booming and
almost Sinister soundtrack that
accompanies his appearance and initial
attack on gamma 2. something I found
interesting as well is that there are
slight differences between toriyama's
initial design of this character and the
illustration Kubota Drew for the
purposes of this film at first glance it
looks like they're the same image almost
traced with a pilot swap on the clothes
but if you look closely the shapes in
toriyamas are much softer and well I
would argue nicer compared to the boxier
and perhaps stiffer Kubota however the
Anatomy on the arm of cabotas makes a
lot more sense with his illustration
allowing Piccolo to actually sort of
look like he's taking steps forward
foreign
that does it I gotta draw this guy
sometime I love him that much like holy
hell if you're an artist you'll know
that this is the highest compliment of
which we are capable
personally I don't think I have an issue
with Cell Max as a concept or as a
character really he is so demonstrably
different to perfect sale Mr Perfect
cell even semi-perfect cell of which is
based that I can't even be upset I
wouldn't even consider him a character
of any description necessarily he has a
character design I guess but his
operation in the plot feels more like a
doomsday weapon than an actual character
with needs and wants I sort of think of
him almost like a Kaiju monster and I
think that offers some Max something
perfect cell didn't have he becomes
something that amplifies the utility and
personalities of characters that
interact with him specifically where
perfect cell was a character into and of
himself that could carry a given scene
Cell Max requires others to interact
with him to demonstrate how great they
are for instance when he first shows up
immediately he elevates the Gammas
unlike Gohan Piccolo and all the others
that suddenly arrive in bulma's dead
both Gamma 1 and Gamma 2 immediately
dive into action to save their creator I
love these characters and through this
Act of altruism we learned that Cell Max
has a weak point programmed into him in
other words doing the right thing in
this instance effectively made Victory
possible I don't think there's anything
more superhero than that
[Music]
this was for me one of the best moments
in this film what a powerful sacrifice
and so incredibly depicted missing its
marks slightly leaving Piccolo to block
the final crushing attack on the now
lifeless colorless husk of gamma 2. and
speaking of color it's around this point
that all the special effects animation
comes into play so what better time to
talk about the production of this film
[Music]
the notion of transitioning Dragon Ball
from 2D into 3D is a truly scary
Prospect given toriyama's style is one
that actively ignores 3D space in the
name of looking cool now what does that
mean looking cool well Goku's hair flips
around like Mickey Mouse's ears the
mouths on these characters slide off at
three-quarter angles along with the fair
eye compressing and furthermore for
years video games across the board have
failed to really capture Dragon Ball 100
accurately something all always kind of
felt off or in some cases diarrhea it
wasn't until however Fighters came along
that we started to really see what was
possible to achieve in the 3D medium by
dynamically breaking the models and
moving things around depending on the
angle Dragon Ball finally looked correct
in 3D the weight for this movie however
was scary the majority of the trailers
focused really hard on the Goku and
Vegeta section of the movie which is a
really short segment and inexplicably
ugly for some reason but the day
eventually came and finally as I
mentioned I got the chance to sit down
and watch this film and they'll relief
let me tell you dear God the relief
while the sections on beerus's planet
aren't great the rest of the movie is a
real visible spectacle and fully takes
advantage of the approach seen in
Fighters switching things up from now
hiroshintani who worked on the Broly
movie we get in this film the character
designs and animation supervision of
none other than shikashi Kubota someone
many of you will probably know as the
character designer for the one punch Man
anime but as it happens he's also a huge
Dragon Ball nerd having released his own
art book for the series and animated a
big part of the climax in the recent
Broly movie his super rigid and detailed
approach here however while probably not
best suited for 2D given its complexity
worked incredibly well in 3D and brings
us right back to the classic late Z era
style much to the Delight of many once
that 2D opening was released I'm sure
now that's not to say our beloved
chintani who brought us into a new era
of Dragon Ball with the recent movie was
ousted he's still very much present here
in a big way doing some character
designs himself and also one huge aspect
I'll touch on later thanks to the
awesome production pipeline created for
the purposes of this film specifically
in many ways this is a legitimate
collaboration between 2D animators and
the CG teams and this is where it gets a
little nerdy but I promise it's
interesting like 2D Productions 3D
production begins with a discussion on
how to visualize the scenes described on
the script which then becomes something
known as a storyboard these roughs
Encompass the entire film and serve
really as the blueprint after that the
scenes are then delegated to 3D
animators who will animate a rudimentary
layout based on the storyboards
admittedly they look incredibly potato
at this point since there's no lighting
and they're using only placeholder
assets but it's important because this
is the foundation of the movement used
in the film and it has to be approved by
the 3D supervisors before going forward
the next stage is where things really
start to come together more the basic 2D
anime effect is added there's additional
written done now Gohan actually has a
facial expression it's starting to get
there but now the 2D staff come into
play in this case Kubota takes these 3D
scenes and draws 2D Corrections over the
top of them it's basically the same way
that supervisors would correct work on a
2d production except instead of a 2d
animator tracing the corrections onto
their work the CG team uses them as a
reference to alter the model to match
these Corrections and that's the
important difference here once complete
the scene is now ready to have its final
lighting applied along with any last
minute details and it really helps to
bring the production to life here you
can see Gohan's hair has appropriate
shading to it and the background
elements finally get a real texture
applied following this 2D animators
finally get to jump back in and draw
Corrections directly onto the work
correcting needless muscle detailing
Gohan's arms for example drawing the
crotch fills property and whatnot in the
action scenes however this step also
involves drawing 2D effects like impact
frames beams and smoke and other special
effects interestingly the fan base's
beloved yuya Takahashi famous for
producing some of the Fantastic scenes
from Super on screen right now was one
of the animators who contributed a bunch
of the effects in fact long story short
the production for this film was a truly
intensive process with the collaboration
between the two teams resulting in a
final product that feels not only
polished but importantly super authentic
it doesn't just end here though one of
the coolest aspects of the film itself
is that a great deal of the 3D movement
is based on 2D animation that was
produced as a reference for example now
hiroshintani drew a layout for the
seller vs Piccolo fight at the end that
was apparently so detailed his fellow
staff said it could have straight up
been used as a 2d production it moved
that well and was that complete this is
something that is insanely common in
Disney's CG Productions you can find a
bunch of pencil tests for their work so
it's cool to hear that toei took a
similar approach in this area on the
back of all of this I wish I could
highlight the 3D animators directly on
this film as they obviously deserve a
huge amount of credit here the character
animation in particular is so full of
life and the little nuances that take
full advantage of 3D are great to see
for instance I love the extra mile this
film went to in order to create visual
interest in the absence of narrative
Intrigue whether it be how expressive
certain characters are in dialogue heavy
exchanges or how simple visual stories
are added to these scenes to give the
audience something to focus on and laugh
at during sometimes more mundane
occurrences unfortunately the nature of
3D also means that individual traits
don't exist like they do in 2D so unlike
the 2D Productions where I might
recognize how one artist might draw an
ear or a nose I can't point to a
specific trait for a 3D production as an
animator's calling card but I did want
to just take a moment to really
highlight how impressive their work is
here translating Dragon Ball into 3D
isn't easy but they really nailed it
this could have been a visual disaster
but the collaborative efforts of
everyone involved resulted in something
that genuinely impressed me we'll maybe
just ignore those janky beerus Planet
scenes though
I think it's time for me to finally talk
about what everyone seems to either be
praising or complaining about in this
film and that is
Beast Gohan
SOS elephant cell Rojo
I don't think this scene can justifiably
be entirely disliked or liked by myself
realistically as it has in my view both
positive and negative attributes
narratively with that said beast Gohan
is by a wide margin the single most
controversial attribute introduced in
this film so let's talk about what I
thought I've seen a lot of people talk
and complain about this feeling like a
tired way of introducing a new form for
the character when you look at the
circumstances being Gohan fighting Cell
drawing on anger only to assume a brand
new power it's easy to see the
repetition of this plane as day however
repetition on its own simply cannot be
the issue here Goku has trained to
progress largely the same way over the
years why do I not take issues with his
transformations of progression the same
way I seem to be doing with Gohan well
firstly you're not going to find an
admirer of forms like super saiyan blue
here though there are meaningful
differences between the likes of Super
Saiyan the god forms and Ultra Instinct
that allow them to feel distinct from
when one another however that's also not
to say that what Gohan experiences
doesn't also feel different with Beast
go however concerning Goku's progression
all of these resulting Transformations
come about as the result of who Goku is
and are emblematic of the journey he was
on during the times of their acquisition
in other words when it comes to Goku all
of his progress comes about naturally
through the forward progression of the
story and through the desirable traits
of his character traits like an
eagerness to fight and improve and while
Gohan has improved through various means
in the past it feels like it always for
Gohan boils down to this Awakening
aspect of his character and its
relationship with Transformations or
progression in the story and on one hand
it's easy to see why this is the case
Gohan's anger was incredibly cathartic
for audiences and an impressively
effective means of breakthrough the
first time narratively I don't need to
tell anyone how amazing the first Super
Saiyan 2 transformation was against
perfect cell but I think it worked
because it happened just once now you
might be saying didn't Gohan rage over
and over and over again in the series
prior to that one moment at the end of
the cell Saga and the answer is yes and
even when talking about Beast Gohan
prior to the film Akira Toriyama had
this to say Gohan's had quite a few
transformations in the past but this
time he needed to awaken to a new one
Gohan has achieved his own unique
Evolution based off of the sort of
Awakenings he's had as a boy I've even
named this transformation Son Gohan
beast in the sense that the Wild Beast
Within him has awoken I don't know how
to feel about this personally but once
you let the genie out of the bottle so
to speak you can't really awaken him
again and again and again without it
feeling cheaper each and every time
diminishing returns is a very real thing
you can only be so awake or are we meant
to understand that he goes back to sleep
following these moments again in which
case this is neither progress nor
regression just something that happens
but many might be asking is there Merit
to this new form is it as bad as other
people seem to be claiming is there
something significant narratively being
built upon here well yes and no it
depends on how you look at it really the
quality of quote Gohan's anger in Dragon
Ball Z wasn't a tribute that yes defined
his character but was also something his
character struggled with and built up to
a dilemma he contended with until
finally that moment came during his
outing against cell during which he
snapped not just out of anger like he
had done dozens and dozens of times
prior but along with that came a newly
found resolve and conviction that was
what made that moment significant for
Millions not because of his anger alone
because he got angry and decided to go
all out afterwards the success of that
moment and indeed the story the
character of Gohan went on to have in Z
is part of the reason he struggles in
some instances to resonate on a
comparatively intense level with a wider
audience now I don't think that it's a
coincidence the characters had more
detractors for his post-cell material
than he enjoyed prior however regardless
of how one might feel about it the
character had grown past that moment and
in some cases brilliantly so with the
story of the Buu saga reflecting that
and the story he enjoyed in super
building off of that idea to progress
and to grow as someone that was no
longer a boy but a man and now a father
to find a path forward that allows him
to be who he is and one that also forces
him to address his imminent
responsibilities as one of the Earth's
most powerful Defenders and personally
the Highlight for his character for me
comes in how we've seen him grow not
only in super but also this very film
the use of makanko sapo here speaks to
that growth and is 100 narratively and
emotionally fulfilling to see as he puts
down Cell Max using it it highlights the
growth Gohan has made since cell all the
while undercutting the suspected
distance forming between Piccolo and
Gohan established earlier on as nothing
more than Gohan Having learned his
lesson now training alone off screen
without the need for Piccolo to
constantly remind him furthermore
musically the moment is stunning as
Gohan is achieving this ultimate beastly
form and the action has built up to an
incredible Peak you would expect some
high energy battle theme to be playing
for the transformation and final blow
but Sato rather chooses to completely
subvert that expectation and play to the
quiet Rage of the form the entire
climactic sequence bathed in rays of
purple and greens from the fighters is
accompanied with an immaculately
understated atmospheric piece of music
no huge horn sections blasting away as a
key blast is charged just soft strings
and synth holding on a single note as a
quiet guitar gently Whispers In and Out
of existence once in a while of course
there will be nothing wrong with a more
traditionally climactic track for this
moment but I think we can all agree that
this more subversive approach helps
cement this moment in the minds of every
single viewer as something truly special
furthermore actively achieving what I
saw this film setting up magenta
manipulates Dr hedo into being another
brilliant scientist like gero for him to
utilize and Piccolo attempts to
manipulate Gohan into being who he wants
him to be however both soon realize how
wrong their initial impressions of these
two were later in the film with hero
being far more virtuous than his late
grandfather and Gohan having indeed
continued to grow and train without the
spotlight and watchful eye of his
one-time mentor and master that's a
great structure with appropriately
contrasting forces of Good and Evil in
the mix only the film doesn't really let
that be the case at least not entirely
instead of becoming the sort of person
he needed to be during the Cell Games
we're reminded that Gohan frustratingly
is still very much that individual who
can seem to be of meaningful value to
the team that can't be the game changer
he could be without first emotionally
breaking to remind him of what he's
truly fighting for yet another good
Android Bites the Dust Piccolo on the
edge of death and perhaps in that same
vein following this negative threat
perhaps I'm being too charitable in
categorizing Gohan as someone mindful of
what might await in the future he
mentions later in the film that he's
been keeping up with his training but I
ask why earlier in the film when Piccolo
tells him to keep up his training Gohan
asks why and wonders if something bad
could actually happen to the Earth again
he actually wonders this this is such an
offensively stupid thing for this
character to say I personally think if
there's any character that should know
how turbulent the world can be if
there's anyone that should understand
how suddenly everything can go to hell
it should be Gohan it's been his entire
life and so while I can acknowledge what
the film is trying to say with Gohan's
character I find myself walking a
tightrope where the margin of error is
so easily trespassed into am I being too
harsh or too charitable if I've made
anything clear during this analysis of
Gohan's big moment of the film it's that
I feel extremely conflicted in one
breath relieved and thrilled they seem
to be progressing the character and in
another utterly frustrated and deflated
at the thought of this being another
moment exactly like what existed before
awkwardly inserted for the sake of
saying hey remember that however it is
important to highlight that during this
transformation Gohan feels distinctly
different with the arrogance he once
postured as a child no longer present
however it does still feel at odds to me
the Beast Gohan character aesthetic and
visual hearkens back to imagery from his
character's greatest moments up until
now Gohan's appearance as a child during
the cell game stood in stark contrast
with the rest of his character's journey
and Visually that made sense to me I
liked how the Buu saga wanted to give
him his own identity free from the
shackles of a Super Saiyan's
expectations a sentiment which was
echoed in Super's manga fittingly and I
loved the narrative Direction Super's
anime took the character highlighting
his arrogance against cell and boo
specifically forcing him to become the
man he was always meant to be and while
I love the use of the mcconko sapo by
Gohan in this film with it being easily
one of the best single moments his
character has contributed to since cell
the fact that it's framed in this
strangely and frankly dated
interpretation of the character
aesthetically feels at odds with what
the moment represents to me personally
the giant spiked hair so familiar and
fitting to the arrogance of a young boy
back then seems to have returned and
perhaps appropriately the crown now
doesn't seem to sit comfortably on the
head of this young father anymore almost
like it's forcing an appearance upon
this man of which he's personally
outgrown however alternatively one could
look at this familiar and lofty shape as
his reclaiming of who he once was at the
height of his character's popularity
while the color shift away from the
golden spectacle he boasted during the
cell Saga might also indicate this
noticeable sense of responsibility he
retains while in this form that replaces
the arrogance he embodied during his
younger years once he did Cut Loose
maybe this form is a perfect marriage
between the states of being the Gohan
character has explored opening him up to
embracing what makes who he is as a
character different now maybe maybe I'm
being too cynical maybe I'm being too
charitable or maybe Akira Toriyama just
thought it looked cool whatever the case
you can decide how you feel for
yourselves in my opinion the climax
didn't need Gohan to transform the way
that he did because he had already
transformed in another more meaningful
way that actually mattered in the past
transformations in Dragon Ball signified
a change in mentality it grows beyond
who they once were freeing them to
explode past their latent potential and
do wondrous things as a result result in
this new form the new form didn't bring
about a new personality this new outlook
brought about that new form how they
looked aesthetically while important for
selling toys and admittedly bonding us
to the character was sort of secondary
with the story itself narratively
interweaving the physical changes with
the emotional and spiritual change that
would occur within the character itself
unlike these past occurrences however
despite Dragon Ball super superhero
brandishing a shiny new transformation
for the character that has undergone
personal growth the form and the growth
integral for the transformation to work
in my mind feel entirely disconnected
from each other the reason why Gohan's
Super Saiyan 2 transformation worked so
powerfully was because it was not just
built up to but represented an instance
in time where the character changed both
emotionally and physically together in
this film the emotion and physical
changes feel entirely disconnected from
one another a character having achieved
a sense of personal growth worthy of
praise and celebration off-screen then
undercut by a transformation that feels
like it's scratching and clawing to
recapture what it once was despite the
character now having outgrown it and I
don't think that's fair fair for this
film or fair for it to be a person's
parting feelings concerning it there
were plenty of criticisms I offered in
good faith towards this film but that
isn't to suggest I disliked it at all
because as I mentioned at the beginning
of this video this is almost a perfect
Dragon Ball film to me it's filled with
so much character passion and lore that
upon watching it for my second and
eventually third times around I only
fell in love with it all the more this
film I don't think was ever designed to
shake things up or present the dragon
ball cannon with anything Monumental and
I think that's okay Transformations
aside I think this film had a lot of
heart and at the end of the day a single
moment in time that I didn't enjoy isn't
enough to bring down a film like this
for me because once again this is a
movie about preserving what was through
sacrifice through heroism whether it be
through gamma's sacrifice or whether it
be through this film's touching ending
pan eagerly awaiting to demonstrate her
Newfound ability to soar High into the
air if there's anything I've learned
this year it's that what we have right
now can be taken away at any moment but
similarly to this film's Final Moments
we should always be able to find solace
in the fact that no matter how bad
things get time always Zan the young
progressed forward and there will always
be something new around the next corner
[Music]
I hope I've perhaps encouraged some of
you out there who might have written off
this film entirely to at least give it
another shot it starts slower than I'd
like personally but once it does get
going it's a very fun ride hopefully
Dragon Ball can carry this momentum
onwards to whatever their next
production will be but until then I hope
you enjoyed this video and thank you so
much for the love and support this year
happy Christmas happy holidays and a
very Happy New Year to one and all oh
also this film has a post-credits scene
and after all the praise I've given this
movie for being faithful to the genre
that might just be the most superhero
movie thing this film has done yet
[Music]
it's over
go home